c'est l'heure de notre second débat
consacré donc au résultat des élections
présidentielles au Brésil Lula favori
des sondages arrive en tête mais le
président sortant d'ailleurs bolsonaro
fait mieux résister l'ancre l'extrême
droite dans le paysage politique
brésilien ça vient de chia il y aura
bien un match retour pour prendre la
tête du Brésil il opposera Louis
signature ou la Da Silva ajaïr bolsonaro
et il sera serré hier le leader de
gauche a obtenu 48% des voix contre 43%
pour le président sortant d'extrême
droite moins de 5 points séparent les
deux candidats alors que les sondages de
l'Institut datafola promettait un écart
de 14%, mais les sondages se sont
trompés Jaïr bolsonaro a fait bien mieux
que prévu
nous avons vaincu les mensonges
aujourd'hui ceux de datafola qui donnait
un résultat de 51% contre 30%. nous
avons vaincu les mensonges faisait lui
Lula va finalement devoir batailler pour
regagner la présidence qu'il a quitté en
2010 au sommet de sa popularité après 8
ans de pouvoir mais entre-temps un
procès pour corruption la mener 580
jours en prison avant que ces
condamnations soient annulées en 2020
l'ancien métal au manque de peu la
victoire au premier tour et repart pour
quatre semaines de campagne
je n'ai jamais gagné une élection au
premier tour il me semble que le destin
aime me faire travailler un peu plus dur
dans les rangs du Parti des travailleurs
ont fait bonne figure mais beaucoup sont
inquiets
j'espère que Lula gagnera je pense qu'il
parviendra à être élu mais que
l'élection sera très serrée
pour départager les poids lourds deux
outsiders se retrouvent désormais au
centre du jeu Simone TB et sirogomez
arrivés en troisième et quatrième
position du scrutin peste à eux de 8
millions de voix ce sont sans doute
leurs électeurs ceux du centre qui
feront la différence le 30 octobre dans
un pays plus que j'aime et polarisé
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités pour ce débat autour des
résultats du premier tour d'éjection
présidentielle au Brésil Armel Henders
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes historienne
spécialiste du Brésil contemporain
professeur à l'Université Paris 8
Vincennes Saint-Denis et auteur de cette
histoire du Brésil publié aux éditions
chandaignes j'accueille également
Christophe venturet bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'IRIS spécial
Amérique latine auteur de géopolitique
de l'Amérique latine cet apparaître
cette semaine le 6 octobre aux éditions
Eyrolles Anne Lauren Bujon bonsoir
bienvenue heureux de vous accueillir
vous êtes directrice de la rédaction de
la revue Esprit qu'on va voir voilà une
tiens il était une fois le travail
social c'est la une de ce mois-ci vous
êtes également chercheuse associée au
programme États-Unis à l'IFRI et Mathieu
croissanto et toujours là toujours
éditorialiste politique bonsoir Mathieu
peut-être on va commencer par le premier
enseignement de de ce scrutin moi j'ai
envie de dire la surprise bolsonaro
c'est un peu évident il est toujours en
alors que les instituts de sondage
peut-être donner une victoire de Lula
jusqu'au jusqu'au dernier jour ils l'ont
quoi sous-estimé vous diriez ça oui
sous-estimé et puis sans doute les
électeurs se sont mobilisés très très
tardivement on choisit hésiter peut-être
entre deux autres candidats ceux qui
sont arrivés en 3e et 4e position
Simonetti
se sont dit
mu soit par enfin par le sans doute
l'idée que nous là pouvait l'emporter au
premier tour d'apporter finalement leur
suffrage à bolsonaro et puis on a ce
qu'on a sous-estimé c'est effectivement
le bolsonarisme comme force politique ça
on va le détailler évidemment parce que
c'est très intéressant notamment les
résultats au Congrès Christophe Ventura
vous l'avez un peu évoqué l'autre leçon
du scrutin c'est quand même la forte
mobilisation des deux camps principaux
quoi eux deux ils font quoi 91% des
suffrages et exprimés ça veut dire que
les petits candidats n'ont tout
simplement pas existé et ça veut dire
qu'on a eu un Brésil très
très antagoniste on peut dire ça veut
dire tout ça et je pense que le résultat
final en fait il est plus proche il est
plus conforme à la réalité
sociopolitique du Brésil en 2022 qui est
un pays très polarisé où les dynamiques
de fragmentation politique de
radicalisation aussi des espaces
militants des espaces politiques et bien
sont des dynamiques très fortes qu'on
observe au Brésil pas simplement là dans
la campagne électorale mais depuis
plusieurs années et au moins depuis la
destitution controversée de la
présidentielle président du maroussef
tout le reste n'est que la le
sous-produit donc oui le résultat il
montre bien ça il y a deux comment dire
il y aurait finalement deux pays dans un
pays qui ne se supportent plus qui se
regardent et qui s'agresse en permanence
et ce pays dans une situation
effectivement vraiment très très
préoccupante pour son avenir quel que
soit le vainqueur de l'élection le 30
octobre désormais à Laurie Bujon pense
immédiatement aux États-Unis quand on
entend ça le parallèle on va le faire
plusieurs fois dans ce débat d'ailleurs
mais oui donc moi très intéressé
d'entendre les gens qui connaissent le
Brésil mais c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de pas faire le parallèle avec
toutes les limites qui s'imposent donc
et sur la polarisation extrême et sur la
mobilisation pour une élection au moment
où on nous parle de démocratie
dépolitiser de des amours de la
politique et on voit les gens qui seront
aux urnes en masse et sur aussi je crois
peut-être qu'il faut faire un petit mea
culpa et quand en 2017 puis 2018 nous
observateurs extérieurs on s'est dit bon
l'élection d'entre Trump l'élection d'un
bolsonaro c'est une sorte d'accident de
l'histoire c'est une anomalie c'est
totalement incompréhensible mais ça
s'est passé une fois mais ça se passera
pas deux fois et là je crois que dans
les deux pays on est face à la
possibilité que oui c'est c'est courant
politique ce sont agrégés installés
parfois encore radicalisé si on pense
entre trumpisme et que peut-être qu'il
pourrait être là pour pour un moment au
contraire on peut rajouter à la liste
des pays européens l'Italie la Suède
récemment la France depuis deux
élections présidentielles consécutives
Marine Le Pen aux second tour de
l'élection enfin bon voilà donc il faut
reconnaître
on est dans un courant de fond dans un
mouvement de fond est-ce que vous diriez
ensuite n'est sans doute pas fait de la
même chose dans chacun de ces pays donc
il faut faire attention mais c'est vrai
que ces espèces de d'élan d'énergie
anti-système dont on a pensé qu'elle se
qu'elle s'autodétruirait toute seule une
fois s'efforce politique portée au
pouvoir et bien non en fait l'épreuve du
pouvoir est y compris d'un mandat qu'on
peut juger catastrophique ne suffit pas
à interdire la réélection de ces leaders
qu'on peut juger par ailleurs démagogues
ou populiste alors il y a un mois de
campagne entre les entre les deux tours
au Brésil Hermann Henders donc il y a
ces deux candidats qui ont fait 4 % et
3% qui vont être forcément très très
courtisés ils sont plutôt proches de qui
de Lula de bolsonaro ni l'un ni l'autre
c'est le grand mystère en fait
plutôt leur organisation sirogomme qui a
fait 3 % chercher à être la troisième
voie et à ses droitsé alors que son sont
pas le parti qui est donc il était le
candidat le Pdt est un vieux parti de
gauche très tradition gauche brésilienne
important et donc il y aura sans doute
un divorce ceux qui sont partis chez
bolsonaro l'ont déjà fait à mon avis
mais là il y a peut-être un réservoir
cela dit les tensions tellement grandes
oui ils sont tellement grandes entre le
entre le Pdt enfin surtout si rogum et
Lola que c'est c'est
vraiment pas clair après les électeurs
suivront leur voix et le mystère c'est
pour le MDB de Simone et Québec qui en
fait de NDB généralement se partagent
entre la droite et la gauche à peu près
à peu près de manière à peu près
équivalente sauf que maintenant il y a
plus de droite en fait il y a une
extrême droite seulement
dès 2018 en fait mais là dans son
bastion qui était l'état de Sampa l'état
le plus riche pour la première fois
depuis la redémocratisation le le
gouverneur sortant enfin le gouverneur
PSD enfin le candidat du psbb au
gouvernement de Saint-Paul n'arrive même
pas au deuxième tour alors on va là ça
c'était un peu le l'analyse on va dire
général du scrutin je vous propose
maintenant d'abord un gros plan sur
bolsonaro et sa campagne et peut-être
aussi de bilan vous l'avez évoqué de son
mandat et puis ensuite on parlera plus
précisément de Lula Steve Jourdain vous
pouvez nous vous rejoindre pour lui
proposer donc le bilan de Jaeger
bolsonaro d'abord en manière en matière
pardon environnementale une politique
catastrophique en matière écologique
c'est l'une des grandes critiques un
formulées par ces opposants et les
associations j'ai un bolsonaro et
climato-sceptique qui le revendique et
encourage depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
en janvier 2019 l'exploitation de la
forêt
amazonienne la conséquence on va la voir
entre 2019 et 2020 la déforestation a
augmenté de plus de 50% à présent chaque
jour au Brésil un million 500 000 arbres
sont abattus c'est l'équivalent de 4000
terrains de foot alors la déforestation
de l'Amazonie n'a pas commencé
évidemment avec balsanaro mais on parle
d'un rythme inédit depuis 20 ans d'ici à
la fin de l'année près de 40 000 km de
forêt tropicale ont été rasés en trois
ans c'est l'équivalent d'une surface
supérieure à la Belgique demain alors en
matière économique et sociale maintenant
est-ce que le bilan du président sortant
est plus flatteur le Brésil était déjà
un pays très inégalitaire et les années
bolsonaro non pas permis de juguler le
phénomène aujourd'hui 33 millions de
Brésiliens souffrent de la fin c'est 15%
de la population un chiffre qui est en
hausse de 73% par rapport à 2020
bolsonaro avait été lu sur une promesse
de libéralisation de l'économie
d'ouverture du pays mais on a vu très
peu de traduction en pratique pas de
bouleversement pas de réforme
structurelle à noter qu'il a quand même
augmenté le budget des prestations
sociales de 7, 6 milliards d'euros et
puis sur le front de l'emploi il y a du
mieux ces derniers mois il faut le dire
le taux de chômage est aujourd'hui de
8,9% c'est son plus bas niveau depuis
2015 il avait également été élu sur une
promesse celle d'un renforcement de la
sécurité des Brésiliens là aussi le
bilan mitigé plutôt mitigé gérable
promis d'armer les Brésiliens pour
lutter contre l'insécurité et les
homicides ce qui est sûr c'est que le
nombre de personnes possédant une arme à
augmenter sous sa présidence les permis
de possession d'armes ont littéralement
explosé plus
464% entre 2018 et 2022 en 4 ans le nom
de personnes disposant d'une licence est
passée de moins de 120 000 après de 700
000 on a aussi assisté au grand boom des
milices privées alors la question c'est
évidemment de savoir si ces phénomène
ont permis de freiner les homicides la
réponse est plutôt mitigée le taux de
mort violente intentionnelle pour 100
habitants avait déjà commencé à baisser
en 2018 c'est-à-dire donc avant
l'arrivée de bolsonaro au pouvoir mais
on va continuer à baisser ensuite entre
2019 et aujourd'hui l'indicateur a
baissé de
1,76% les chiffres sont là mais il faut
encore les interpréter merci Steve Armel
Sanders pardon en préparant le
l'émission j'ai appris moi je suis pas
un spécialiste du Brésil qui avait les
dans les lobbys qui soutiennent
bolsonaro il y avait les trois B alors
en français c'est la Bible le bœuf et
les balles je sais pas comment ça se dit
en brésilien qu'est-ce qu'il y a
derrière ça expliquez-nous il y a
effectivement des lobbies extrêmement
puissants alors le plus puissant c'est
sans doute celui du bœuf boy qui en fait
envoie l'industrie à agroalimentaire et
qui est qui reste le principal soutien
de bolsonaro là sont des intérêts très
puissants ça explique aussi le vote
massif pour bolsonaro dans les régions
de colonisation dans le bassin amazonien
dans les états où vous avez la
déforestation et
et l'extension de ces de ces de ses
propriétés au détriment de de la de la
forêt la Bible ce sont les évangéliques
qui là aussi après un moment il y avait
un léger détachement par rapport à la
personne de bolsonaro mais visiblement
ils sont ils ont choisi de voter pour
lui comme garant de la campagne de
bolsonaro c'est c'est beaucoup appuyé et
notamment sur sa femme Michel
évangélique elle-même et pour pour
présenter et bossaros est présenté comme
le comme
[Musique]
l'élu un élu l'élu de Dieu pour mener à
bien une mission et faire conserver le
Brésil dans le giron dans le giron
chrétien
et puis les armes c'est extrêmement
important effectivement il y a aussi des
grandes production brésilienne les armes
la société Taurus ou les exportations
brésiliennes c'est c'est des armes aussi
et ça c'est très important alors
j'ajoute un petit quelque chose sur ce
qui a été dit les milices privées
attention ce sont des organisations
criminelles et ça c'est un des grands
problèmes de la société brésilienne et
c'est de là aussi que bolsonaro et son
clan tire leur pouvoir dans l'État de
Rio de Janeiro ce sont des agents alors
ce que je vous dis là ça n'est pas ça a
été ça fait l'objet d'une enquête
parlementaire de l'Assemblée de Rio en
2007 qui a
dénoncé ces organisations sont elles
sont sont des petites mafia composées en
général enfin d'agents d'ancien agent ou
d'agent de la fonction de les publics de
l'État de Rio de Janeiro d'anciens
policiers ou de policiers à la retraite
qui font de la de la surveillance mais
qui au fond
maintenant contrôle 57% du territoire
municipal de Rio de Janeiro et on fait
ont pris la place des trafics en drogue
dans la plupart des dans la plupart des
de ces groupes là sont dans le giron
bolsonaro aussi
toute une rhétorique qui vise à dire que
ce sont des des gens des citoyens du
bien qui protègent leur concitoyens et
qui mènent une guerre impitoyable contre
les trafiquants la drogue etc mais en
fait ce sont des tueurs à gages des avec
beaucoup de connexion avec l'extrême
droite brésilienne tiens on va écouter
l'un des soutiens ça rejoint un peu ce
que vous disiez sur l'aspect religieux
l'un des soutiens du président sortant
l'un de ces partisans c'était lors de
son dernier meeting de campagne qui se
déroulait à San Paolo
l'idéologie de bolsonaro son idéologie
qui correspond à ce peuple ici le peuple
chrétien n'a pas besoin de l'avortement
et nous n'avons pas besoin de
l'idéologie du genre et aussi nous
n'avons pas besoin de la légalisation
des drones
Christophe Ventura sur les questions on
va dire les plus religieuses qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait bolsonaro pendant son
premier mandat est-ce qu'il a
effectivement durci par exemple
législation sur l'avortement est-ce
qu'il a contré l'idéologie du genre
comme le dit là l'un de ses partisans
bah déjà il a eu cesse de la dénoncer
d'ailleurs de la nommer à idéologie du
genre alors que beaucoup contestent même
la définition
il a beaucoup parlé son grand thème
c'est l'inversion des valeurs c'est
là-dessus qu'il a fait une campagne en
2018 et c'est ce qui essaie de après
c'est de mettre en place dans le pays
alors ça s'est traduit par quoi ça c'est
traduit par le fait non pas de
frontalement interdit ou stigmatiser
ou je sais pas
empêcher les gens de ceci cela c'est pas
ça c'est plus subtil ce qu'il a fait
c'est que il a tout il organisé un peu
la mort des programmes qui étaient mis
en place pour soutenir ces populations
par inanition en quelque sorte fin des
financesment on a des capitaux dans pas
mal d'instituts d'institutions les gens
qui les dirigeaient qui menaient en
place les programmes etc donc surtout la
fin des financements j'irai c'est ça qui
a été fait ce qui fait que petit à petit
en fait tous ces programmes-là ont
quasiment un peu disparu avec un
discours aussi vraiment à charge contre
par exemple tout ce qui est lié aux
questions de genre etc dans l'éducation
dans les écoles donc là dessus il y a eu
des gens qui ont des profs qui ont dû
être dénoncés il y avait un appel à
dénonciation permanente des parents des
enfants sur la prof qui leur parlait
d'égalité de gens etc etc donc c'est
comme ça que ça a fonctionné en fait et
que ça a fonctionné puisque aujourd'hui
tout ça est largement affaibli dans les
institutions
les les en particulier l'école au Brésil
ce qui est intéressant
d'analysé à Noël Bugeon c'est dans
peut-être dans le fonctionnement de de
nos démocraties ou de ces démocraties
c'est-à-dire que on peut dire un peu la
même chose de Trump encore une fois mais
à partir du moment où ils sont
démocratiquement élus ils ont quoi le
sentiment d'un d'un blanc simple de
pouvoir faire un peu ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ça j'ai été élu donc
par exemple sur la déforestation ou sur
d'autres thématiques mais c'est à dire
que on sent une tentation de considérer
une fois élu que il y a une forme de
fusion avec ce qui est la demande d'un
peuple supposément homogène supposément
majoritaire parce que tout ça vient avec
beaucoup de raccourcis et derrière en
fait il peut y avoir des demandes
sociales assez hétérogènes comme on
vient de le voir mais on a pu dire aux
États-Unis je reviens aux États-Unis par
exemple je pense que le mouvement du
type parti a été comme un comme un
signal précurseur de ce qui après avec
l'élection de Trump et qui se consolide
aujourd'hui sous la forme du trumpisme
et ce qu'on voit là c'est quand même un
bloc de classe moyenne plutôt blanche
sur lesquels reposait la prospérité de
toute la deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
pour dire vite qui se sentent déclassés
qui se sentent dépossédés de leur pays
de son identité
supposément éternelle alors que ça bouge
et qui réagissent donc pareil je parle
plutôt des États-Unis que je connais
mieux mais à l'idée que ils vont être
dépossédés de leur Amérique de
l'Amérique telle qu'il la conçoivent eux
et donc on fait appel à ça à des grands
clichés donc ça peut être le port
d'armes ça peut être des formes
d'économie productivistes et prédatrices
alors aux États-Unis c'est pas le boeuf
mais c'est les énergies fossiles par
exemple mais votre Amérique celle qui
sur laquelle on a construit notre
prospérité notre puissance c'est celle
or on est devant des transformations qui
risquent de de changer le pays de telle
sorte qui sera méconnaissable donc il y
a une appel un appel comme ça à une
sorte de pays un peu mythifiés mais ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'il ne
gouvernent que pour ceux qui les ont
élus en fait et ça veut dire que une
fois élu emporté par ce principe
majoritaire nous représentons une
majorité de gens et donc c'est normal de
marcher sur les minorités ou c'est
normal de se dispenser des contrepoids
des institutions démocratiques qui sont
des empêcheurs de tourner en rond d'une
presse qui parle contre vous donc elle
ment donc voilà il y a une de le pour
Trump si vous voulez les États-Unis
c'est lui en effet les vrais États-Unis
et les autres ce sont des gens qui qui
prétendent être des Américains
comme contre-pouvoir à bolsonaro pendant
son mandat qui ont et est-ce qu'ils ont
pu quand même
le freiner sur certaines réformes sur
certaines actions politiques dans un
premier temps il y avait le président de
la Chambre des députés et puis le
président du Sénat aussi qui est là tout
le long du mandat le Sénat résisté mais
là ce qui est nouveau c'est que tout ce
qui est il y a pas seulement bolsonaro
mais il y a aussi il y a eu un certain
nombre d'élections au Sénat comme à la
Chambre des députés qui sont absolument
représentatifs de
du bilan de ce qu'on a présenté comme le
bilan négatif de de bolsona sont son
ancien ministre de l'Environnement qui
était connu pour détruire
l'environnement qui a des affaires enfin
qui est considéré comme un trafiquant de
de bois d'Amazonie il vient d'être élu
triomphalement enfin facilement à la
Chambre des députés je pourrais
multiplier les exemples ce qui est le
général pazoel qui était le ministre le
général ministre de la Santé au pire
moment du covid auquel on attribue
vraiment des responsabilités de dizaines
de milliers de morts au fond par par son
incurie par de la corruption au
ministère de la santé il a été élu aussi
facilement enfin les Brésiliens ne
veulent pas à bolsonaro pour sa gestion
du covid
si vous voulez ces deux camps c'est à
dire que le camp loulac est quand même
48 % des lecteurs
oui mais il y a une forme de déni et je
rejoins ce qui a été dit de déni de
réalité c'est à dire il y a pas de
problème d'environnement il y a pas de
crise énergétique il y avait pas le
covid c'est une espèce de fatalité
divine voilà et
l'hydroxycloroquine c'était formidable
il y a un déni de réalité et de même
effectivement il y a le Brésil c'est
nous enfin le une rhétorique de
l'exclusion par bolsonaro tout ce qui
n'est pas dans notre camp tout ce qui
n'est pas patriote ce sont des ennemis
et des ennemis dont il a dont il appelle
de temps en temps à l'extermination en
cette arme là
un mot justement des élections au
Congrès enfin la Chambre des députés et
au Sénat au Sénat c'est un peu comme
chez nous c'est renouvellement par tiers
il y a quoi il y a une majorité pour
bolsonaro qui est en train de se
dessiner c'est est-ce que c'est aussi
clair que ça en fait cette élection est
très importante peut-être autant que la
présidentielle qu'on analyse ce soir
pourquoi parce que le Congrès brésilien
donc la Chambre des députés et le Sénat
le parti de botswanaro va y avoir les
groupes les plus importants 99 députés
quasiment sans pour son parti à la
Chambre des représentants sur 513 ça
fait quasiment un cinquième et si vous
ajoutez à ça les autres parties alliés
de bolsonaro plus des parties des petits
partis de ce qu'on appelle le sentrao
qui est un peu le ventre mou de la
politique brésilienne il a une majorité
assez assez facile à avoir et il aura
bolsonaro et c'est pareil au Sénat où il
y a le premier groupe aujourd'hui avec
11 sénateurs sur les 81 et c'est la même
chose à l'inverse on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure le Parti des
travailleurs de pas lui va être en
difficulté dans ce congrès là donc le
Congrès il y a une poussée très forte du
bolsonarisme et des droites et donc même
si Lula l'emporte il aura du mal à
gouverner il aura beaucoup de mal à
gouverner parce que si nous la l'emporte
il va devoir gouverner avec une alliance
qui est gauche centre droit ça c'est à
l'exécutif dans au gouvernement mais il
devra gouverner avec un congrès qui lui
sera assez clairement hostile allez-y si
je peux me permettre oui la Chambre des
députés c'est un gros problème au Brésil
parce qu'il y a une fragmentation des
parties donc il est très difficile
d'avoir une majorité nette donc de toute
façon majorité de coalition
sans député enfin de 99 là pour le pour
le sonaro c'est beaucoup c'est un peu
historique voilà mais
on dirait pas énorme en 2018 en 2018
alors que il avait gagné largement
l'élection il en avait eu que 54
et là le nombre de députés du PT a aussi
augmenté
de façon au Brésil les présidents doit
toujours conçu des coalitions par le
mentales ce qui a une vingtaine de
parties au Congrès en fait c'est ce
qu'on appelle une trentaine une
trentaine mais le le dans la
configuration actuelle c'est plus
favorable à bolsonarolas il gagnait
alors on va ouvrir le chapitre concerné
juste consacré pardon justement à Lula
reste-t-il le favori avant d'en débattre
et de vous donner la parole là-dessus on
va Matthieu s'intéresser à au symbole
d'espoir qu'il représente pour la gauche
française et comment il est vu par les
hommes politiques je vous propose une
réaction de gauche pour commencer
va-t-il panneau la présidente du groupe
LFI à l'Assemblée c'était sur LCI ce
matin
est en tête et que ça serait un
événement politique majeur pour nous
pourquoi parce que ça serait la première
fois qu'il y a dans autant de pays du
continent américain des gauches de
rupture qui sont gouvernement comme ça
se passe dans beaucoup des pays parce
que c'est l'intérêt de la France parce
que nous la plus longue frontière de la
France et avec le Brésil en Guyane et
parce que surtout ça serait un espoir
écologique extrêmement fort alors que
Lula est le bolsonaro pardon et le pire
destructeur de l'Amazonie qui est le
poumon après la planète Mathieu cette
élection elle est très suivie ici à
Paris en France
l'élection brésilienne c'est une sorte
de laboratoire assez ouvert pour
reprendre votre expression tout le monde
veut savoir si oui ou non c'était un
accident de l'histoire un petit peu
comme après la défaite de Trump ou si il
y a un mouvement qui perdure et quelle
leçon on peut en tirer alors parce que
les résultats plus sériques prévus ont
donné quel que soit froide là on va
mettre le panneau qui appelle à soutenir
Lula à la victoire de Lula comme tous
les insoumis la droite elle se monte un
peu plus discrète elles sont pas
beaucoup ou alors elle était refuse de
choisir à l'image de Robert Ménard qui
dit ce matin contre les nostalgiques de
la dictature soutenu par les religieux
passéistes un homme de gauche qui
soutient Mélenchon mais le choix des
Brésiliens c'est la peste ou le choléra
et pourtant Loula
les faveurs de la classe politique
française oui bien sûr alors on le
disait à gauche évidemment mais aussi à
l'Élysée ou la version d'Emmanuel Macron
pour sonarn est un secret pour personne
ils sont reposées en tout point sur le
plan politique sur le plan des valeurs
sur le plan environnemental sur le plan
économique leur relation sont aussi
glaciales sur le plan personnel depuis
que bolsonaro s'en est pris à Brigitte
Macron un sommet du G7 à Biarritz en
2019 dans des termes extraordinairement
irrespectueux avait alors réagi Emmanuel
Macron
et voilà donc mais Lula est une icône
lors de son dernier déplacement il est
venu en novembre 2021 à Paris tout le
monde sur l'arrachait il a vu la mère de
Paris Anne Hidalgo qui avait fait venir
dans un de ses meeting qu'il avait des
Corée il a déjeuné avec l'ancien
président de la République François
Hollande et avec le nouveau le même jour
à croire qu'il a pris deux déjeuner ce
jour-là
et puis il a fini évidemment avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il a soutenu et
qu'il a appelé à soutenir au premier
tour de la présidentielle dans une
lettre qui était aussi signée de de
dilmar ouf c'est mon frère dit de lui le
leader des insoumis les deux hommes se
connaissent bien se sont rencontrés à
plusieurs en tout cas ils se connaissent
ils sont rencontrés à plusieurs reprises
le patron des insoumis lui-même rendu
visite alors qu'il était emprisonné dans
les locaux de la police fédérale
brésilienne en 2019 les esprits taquins
retiendront que Jean-Luc Mélenchon on a
peut-être jamais su bien choisir entre
ces deux figures inspirantes
sud-américaines
Lula et sa tentative son approche qu'on
peut qualifier de social-démocrate vous
me corrigerez si je me trompe et puis
évidemment chaise qui incarnait lui la
révolution bolivarienne et qu'il a
toujours un peu balancé entre les deux
et puis on peut rappeler jusqu'au final
Lula a fini par apporter son soutien au
second tour cette fois-ci à Emmanuel
Macron qui incarnait le mieux à ses yeux
les valeurs démocratiques humanistes
face évidemment dans jeu de l'extrême
droite et à Marine Le Pen et Jerry
bolsonaro est-ce qu'il a des soutiens
un nombre j'en ai pas trouvé en France
et politique français non en 2018 Marine
Le Pen avait salué sa victoire elle
avait dit les Brésiliens viennent de
sanctionner la corruption généraliser la
criminalité terrifiante de qui ont qui
avait prospéré selon tous les
gouvernements de gauche et de souhaiter
bonne chance aux nouveaux présidents
qu'elle refusait à l'époque de qualifier
d'extrême droite d'ailleurs des
positions que qui sont difficiles qui
seraient difficile à transposer en
France mais en tout cas on peut pas le
qualifier d'extrême droite
Eric Zemmour à l'époque lui il était
encore éditorialiste il était pas encore
même politique et il voyait dans
bolsonaro un petit frère sud américain
moins de Trump ils sont portaient contre
les mises en garde des médias français
qui brandissaient un risque d'extrême
droite qui disait qu'à ses yeux la seule
dictature dans la région sévit au
Venezuela et elle est de gauche voilà
c'était une autre époque bolsonaro
n'avait pas encore été au pouvoir mais
depuis tous ces excès sa politique son
bilan fond de lui qui est devenu pour
l'échiquier politique français en tout
cas un fréquentable alors gros plan donc
sur Lula dans cette partie de notre
débat armée lenders peut-être pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé c'est à
dire qu'on parle de corruption vous
l'avez rappelé où là il a passé plus de
550 jours en prison il a été quoi il a
été blanchi il a été innocenté il faut
peut-être détailler un peu ce qui ce qui
s'est passé je crois que le caractère
vraiment politicien et contre Lola est
clair maintenant c'est ce que je pense
assez bien établi la Cour suprême après
aussi
l'oeuvre d'un hacker qui avait qui avait
pu révéler les conversations du
procureur et juge qui a seulement
instruit à charge contre Lula et qu'il
avait condamné quand même plus de 8 ans
de prison pour un appartement dont il a
jamais eu l'avait mis les pieds une fois
où il n'avait ou dont on n'a jamais pu
prouver qu'il lui appartenait et en est
qu'il aurait reçu en échange de on ne
sait pas quoi de la même du juge ça fait
quand même beaucoup et c'était tombé sa
carrière politique parce que sinon on a
un peu de mal à comprendre le juge en
question est devenu ensuite ministre et
dépendant la campagne électorale des
dernières présidentielles et pendant
même la campagne le bolsonaro l'avait
invité à faire partie de son
gouvernement donc il avait quand même
réussi à éliminer le principal rival de
bolsonaro lui ouvrant un boulevard bon
c'est donc une affaire quand même
sénateur et désormais sénateur mais
politique
je crois que c'est clair donc quand on a
j'avais assisté au débat de la Cour
suprême pour qui avait conclu à la
partialité du juge on avait le un des
juges de la Cour suprême pourtant pas du
tout supporter de Lola avait dit c'était
des méthodes de la Stasi
voilà donc les élections de 2018 n'a pas
été faite dans des conditions
démocratiques voilà alors ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas eu de corruption
autour de la pétrole mais cela dit c'est
pas le enfin le PTC certes trempé dans
ces histoires là mais c'est si on
prenait les affaires autour de la
famille bolsonaro sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus
d'un mot Cristian Ventura le scandale
qui fait tomber bolsona on a bien
compris vous nous dit Kabbale politique
c'est quoi c'est un des plus grosses
scandales politico-financier de
l'histoire du Brésil si on devait
comparer à parce qu'on en a eu
malheureusement de ce qu'on a positif
aux financer à quelque chose qu'on
connaît en France et l'affaire Elf
d'accord on appelle ça au Brésil c'est
la faire lavage ato lavage Express qui a
démarré en 2014 en fait instruite en
particulier par le juge Sergio Moreau
dont Armel Anderson parler qui
aujourd'hui sénateur élu donc vous voyez
qu'il a encore des ressources malgré
qu'il ait été dévoué par sa hiérarchie
par la Cour suprême etc pour avoir mené
une partiales contre Lula vous savez que
Sergio Moreau avait enfermé Lula sur la
base c'est son expression d'un doute
raisonnable de sa culpabilité qui était
le sien 550 jours de prison voilà donc
effectivement aucune preuve matérielle
de la culpabilité de Lula dans les trois
affaires dont on passe en fait il y en a
11 qui concerneula il a été blanchi
aucun doute là-dessus même au niveau de
des Nations Unies les comités d'experts
ont appuyé tout ça bref donc si vous
voulez la faire c'est lavage Atos c'est
un peu l'équivalent de la faire elle
mais il faut comprendre une chose sinon
on comprend pas le film le système
politique brésilien est fait de telle
manière qu'il favorise la corruption
politique à tous les étages pourquoi on
en a dit quelques bribes comme ça un
système politique où vous avez une
trentaine de parties qui se partagent en
fait toutes les prébendes et les postes
au Congrès dans les ministères etc et
des financements publics qui quasiment
n'existaient pas et qui aujourd'hui se
sont un peu renforcés mais du coup c'est
le financement du secteur privé qui si
vous voulez financer essentiellement les
campagnes politiques au Brésil alors aux
Etats-Unis par exemple pour me dire bah
oui c'est la même chose à peu près aux
États-Unis sauf qu'aux États-Unis il y a
un réglementation du lobbying de ses
parents voilà que certains corruption
légalement
au Brésil c'était pas ça c'était bah ce
qu'on appelle l'Italie je changeais les
combinations c'est à dire on se
débrouille donc comment on se
débrouillait les entreprises privées du
secteur privé payait sur des bases de
surfacturation aux entreprises publiques
qui redistribuaient derrière l'argent à
tous les partis politiques brésiliens
pour qui finance leur campagne et
personne ne trouvait ça odieux et donc
si vous voulez ça a marché comme ça 30
ans et le PT était dans ce
fonctionnement comme tous les autres
Brésil tous les autres partis politiques
brésiliens et même plutôt un peu moins
mais il y a eu cette campagne et des
relais médiatiques très forts contre ce
parti qui était au pouvoir au moment du
scandale et tout ça a créé une boucle
infernale qui aboutit à la destitution
de la dil qui elle était pas du tout
concernée par ses affaires là et puis
une fumée par Lula dans les conditions
qu'on connaît et je dis juste que si je
passe un peu de temps là-dessus c'est
pour faire comprendre à ce qui nous
écoutent que tout ça ça reste
aujourd'hui prégnant dans la société
brésilienne et une partie du vote pro
bolsonaro s'explique encore par cette
haine contre le Parti des Travailleurs
cette haine contre système politique sa
corruption à tous les étages et c'est
quelque chose qui va à la faveur de
botsunaro contre Lula et le parti
travailleur dans une partie électorat en
tout cas et plutôt l'électorat de la
droite brésilienne et urbaine c'est
plutôt eux les classes moyennes
supérieures qui sont sur ce mode là et
c'est encore un élément qu'il faut avoir
en tête pour comprendre le vote d'hier
jusqu'à quel rôle a joué la presse dans
la campagne et dans cette élection
2018 elle a joué un rôle très clair
contre le Parti des Travailleurs il faut
dire les choses comme elles sont les
grands médias traditionnels brésiliens
avaient en fait embrassé cette campagne
anticorruption qui s'est traduite à
partir de 2014 cette fois-ci et c'est ça
qui est quand même assez piquant c'est
que cette fois-ci les
grands médias à l'instar d'ailleurs un
petit peu des secteurs d'affaires des
milieux d'affaires brésiliens après
avoir finalement
voulu l'élimination politique de Lula et
de la gauche ont permis à bolsonaro de
gouverner et l'ont lâché à son tour
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la presse
brésilienne parce qu'elle a été
maltraité Parrot et cetera parce que
bolsonaro se fiche des médias
traditionnels puisqu'il a inventé un
monde parallèle avec les réseaux sociaux
dans lesquels il y a des vérités
alternatives les siennes et bien si vous
voulez les médias ne sont aujourd'hui
contre bolsonaro et bonhomme Malan
rejoignent le consensus autour de Lula
parce que Lula arrive au pouvoir s'il y
arrive pas seul il arrive aussi avec des
gens qui sont plus fréquentable de leur
point de vue que sont des dirigeants ou
des parties du centre droit et disons du
monde de Sao Paulo du milieu des
affaires brésilien qui sont avec Lula
cette fois-ci pour déloger bolsonaro
Lula en Valentin justement c'était hier
soir juste après les résultats de ce
premier tour donc il a 5 points d'avance
sur sur bolsonaro ben il se lance dans
la dans la bagarre du second tour
comme ça la lutte continue jusqu'à la
victoire finale c'est notre devise
on dit comme ça la lutte continue
jusqu'à la victoire finale c'est notre
devise jouet qu'on parle des vous l'avez
un peu évoqué avec vous un Noël Bujon de
du poids des infoges ou des fake news
dans ces campagnes électorales là encore
on peut refaire un parallèle avec les
États-Unis parce que le la puissance de
bolsonaro sur les réseaux sociaux elle
est infiniment plus importante que celle
de Lula et alors elle est moins forte
que celle de Donald Trump mais c'est un
peu le même usage de cette vérité
alternative dont on dont on pouvait
parler oui en fait il faut sans doute je
pense élargir c'est pas juste les
infoges ou les fake news c'est un même
politique et médiatique dans lequel
effectivement tout l'appareillage des
réseaux sociaux permet un leader
charismatique de s'adresser directement
à une multitude de personnes donc
prospérant sur le discrédit d'un ancien
système enfin je suis vraiment très
intéressé par tout ce que vous dites
parce que je me dis aussi
pas non plus le contraire mais c'était
la haine du Parti des Travailleurs donc
c'est en fait si vous voulez c'est comme
s'il y avait des médiations
traditionnelles anciennes qui ont
fonctionné la démocratie représentative
les syndicats enfin voilà beaucoup de
corps intermédiaires qui souffrent d'un
discrédit très avancé les médias dans la
liste et des leaders charismatiques qui
comprennent ça et qui disent que eux ils
vont communiquer autrement et
directement à la multitude et donc comme
on sait sur les réseaux sociaux il y a
absolument tout et n'importe quoi mais
c'est vrai que dans l'analyse de ce qui
se passe autour d'entre Trump ou d'un
bolsonaro on a parfois tendance à dire
bon ce sont des
démagogues ou populistes appelons-les
comme on veut et les réseaux sociaux
leur permettent de prospérer non je
crois pas que c'est ça je crois que
c'est il y a un système politique à
l'ancienne qui va très mal avec une
sorte de sentiment de crise de la
représentation de beaucoup de groupes
sociaux qui pensent que personne ne
parle pour eux que personne ne défend
leurs intérêts et sur ce système qui va
très mal il y a des gens qui prospèrent
dans les failles si vous voulez et en
s'emparons de mode de communication très
différent des intermédiés et ça donne ce
sentiment d'une communication chaotique
mais qui mais qui fonctionne
extraordinairement bien et donc ce sont
des personnages si vous voulez qui qui
prospèrent sur un déficit de
représentation et ils se mettent à
incarner des choses d'une manière
parfois très improbable parce que que ce
soit bolsonaro ou Trump en incarnation
des valeurs chrétiennes de leur pays
respectifs on se dit ah bah non ou du le
peuple des petits blonds américains
ruinés on se dit mais non ce
millionnaire de New York pas du tout
mais il y a cette espèce de sentiment
qui comprend la foule de ces supporters
qu'il est avec eux qu'il est porté par
leur énergie par leur enthousiasme bon
voilà c'est la démagogie
2.0 mais donc c'est pas il y a ça et les
réseaux sociaux
accélèrent ce mouvement c'est je pense
que c'est constitutif de la de la force
politique d'un Trump ou d'un bolsonaro
les résultats de ce premier tour vont
nourrir le discours de bolsonaro parce
que il a pas arrêté de dire les sondages
mentent et puis alors ils ont pas menti
mais ce sont en tout cas un peu trompés
puisque il est seulement à 5 points de
de Lula alors que certains sondages
disaient Lula peut passer dès le premier
tour à plus de 50% donc on peut
s'attendre à quoi dans cette campagne
d'entre-deux tours cette nouvelle
campagne qui commence effectivement la
donne est totalement alors s'il y avait
une telle pression pour que Lula essaye
de passer au retour c'était aussi pour
ce légitimer pour empêcher toute
contestation de l'élection parce que
comme c'est il y a plusieurs élections
au même jour par les journal
électronique si Luna était passé au
premier tour était difficile de remettre
en cause enfin d'appeler à des fraudes
annulait toutes les élections et là il
est sûr que
je vois mal bolsonaro même si le perdait
il va pas perdre de
sans doute ça peut être serré je le vois
mal accepté là le le verdict électoral
et
c'est long à moi
de choses beaucoup de violence aussi
vous pensez qu'il y aura de la violence
forcément bah il y en a déjà
eu quand même trois à trois morts trois
militants du PT qui ont été assassinés
l'un le jour de son anniversaire
donc ça veut dire que poser les affiches
pour le Parti travailliste de Lula ça
peut être dangereux ça peut être
dangereux c'est une grande un grand
changement par rapport à ce qu'il y
avait il y a une quinzaine d'années les
alors cette année les gens ont refait un
peu plus campagne ce sont plus montrées
mais il était tradition de mettre des
autocollants sur sa voiture pour dire
dans quel sur quel et depuis 2014 les
gens font plus parce que c'est c'est
exposé mettre un autocollant du PT c'est
s'exposer à avoir son sa voiture
vandalisée ou alors il y a aussi sans
doute des des violences de l'autre côté
mais elles sont quand même beaucoup plus
du côté de l'extrême droite il y aura un
débat télévisé forcément dans déjà prévu
d'ailleurs Lula hier on a il a fait
référence dans son discours parce qu'il
espère qu'il va se tenir parce que
botswanaro pourrait tout à fait dire
qu'il ne veut pas y participer donc hier
il y a participé avant le premier tour
il y a eu un débat on va voir nous là
hier c'est pas anodin le fait que Lula
est dit dans son discours il est parlé
de ça en disant j'attends le débat tête
à tête en français dans le texte avec le
président donc oui il va avoir lieu ce
débat plein de meeting enfin c'est une
autre campagne parce que parce qu'en
bolsonaro méfie tous les débats et
prétextant alors il avait des bonnes
raisons son état de santé sa blessure
mais enfin ce qu'il avait été agressé
pendant la course
et ça a été une blessure très grave il y
a pas de doute là-dessus le
et il avait il en avait profité alors il
manquait les débats pour raison de santé
mais en même temps il allait se faire
interviewer à la même heure sur une
chaîne ami par un par un pasteur
complaisant donc bon voilà donc l'idée
c'est de le confronter et c'est vraiment
un duel mais enfin au-delà du duel c'est
vraiment deux Brésil deux pays
totalement antagonique et on est dans
une situation
vraiment pas loin d'une guerre civile
sans doute de manière larvée peut-être
de basse intensité mais ces deux pays
qui ne se parlent pas qui ne peuvent pas
se parler qui vivent dans des sphères
différentes et dont les dont les dont
les valeurs sont vraiment à l'opposées
c'est en tout cas l'axe de sa campagne
depuis le départ c'est exactement ça
c'est en gros rassembler tous ceux qui
veulent un Brésil démocratique un état
de droit unir les Brésiliens au-delà de
leurs différences c'est tout le
programme de la campagne de Lula depuis
le démarrage et je pense qu'au deuxième
tour il va encore accélérer là-dessus en
disant justement si c'est pas ça le pays
va avant le coup d'État rampant
fascistoïde va continuer d'avancer si
botsunaro redevint un nouveau mandat si
vous lui confiez de vous mandats donc
c'est ça qui va y avoir c'est unir les
Brésiliens le retour du pays dans la
démocratie et sa dignité face aux
risques d'une aventurisme d'extrême
droite qui continuerait etc et c'est ça
qui va jouer maisonnaro on peut compter
sur lui pour jouer sa partition qui va
être encore de cliver à mort sur ces
mois ou c'est les voleurs qui
reprendront le pouvoir et qui vous
voleront le peu d'argent qui vous reste
je vous promets pas grand chose
mais c'est moi qui vous représente
je remontre la une de ce mois c'est une
consacrée au travail socialiste une fois
le travail social alors melender votre
histoire du Brésil et publié aux
éditions chandaigne et puis Christophe
Ventura on va revoir la couverture de
votre livre géopolitique de l'Amérique
latine qui lui est apparaître là c'est
ce jeudi aux éditions hérol merci encore
à tous merci Mathieu de m'avoir
accompagné dans cette émission qui était
passionnante dommage je vous donne
rendez-vous à 18h et 22h sur Public
Sénat et puis le ratez pas demain matin
vous le voyez juste à côté de moi
l'invité Dorian Mancini c'est Laurent
Fabius le président du Conseil
constitutionnel belle soirée
[Musique]